[موسيقى]
بمجرد رؤية مانتا راي ،
لا يمكنك أن تهتم بوجودهم
في الماء معهم ، فأنت
تدرك مدى
رقيهم ومدى جاذبيتهم [موسيقى] أنا بيث فولكنر وأنا البار أتو
مدير
مشروع مانتا راي الأكثر انحرافًا ، بدأ منتج مانتا راي المالديفي لأول مرة
في عام 2005 في أربعة مواسم من أرض
غارافارو ، وتوسع ببطء في جميع أنحاء
جزر المالديف
في عام 2011 ، وتقرر أنه لا
يكفي مجرد التركيز على المانتاس في
جزر المالديف
وأنه ينبغي العمل عليها في
جميع أنحاء العالم ، وكان هذا عندما
تم تشكيل صندوق مانتا ترست ،
هدفنا أساسًا هو البحث في
أسماك مانتا راي في جميع أنحاء جزر المالديف
ومعرفة المزيد عن علم الأحياء
وسلوكهم وكذلك الأنماط الرئيسية
في حركتهم
[الموسيقى]
لدى جزر المالديف  أكبر عدد
من أسماك شيطان البحر تم تسجيله على الإطلاق في جميع أنحاء العالم ،
لدينا عدد هائل من السكان
وصل إلى ما يقرب من 5000 الآن
من أجل تحديد شعاع مانتا ، سنلتقط
أولاً صورة لبطن
m  أنتا ، حيث توجد البقع ،
لدينا معرض قصبي كبير
يتضمن كل بطن من
المانتاس التي رأيناها حتى الآن
، ثم نلتقط صورنا ونطابقها
مع تلك الموجودة في معرض الشعب الهوائية ،
ونحن دائمًا متحمسون جدًا عندما
نجد  تواجه أسماك شيطان البحر الجديدة
[تصفيق]
العديد من التحديات في جميع
أنحاء العالم بما في ذلك
المصيد العرضي لمصايد الأسماك المستهدفة
وتدهور الموائل ، لذلك هنا في
جزر المالديف ، فإن فقدان موائلها هو
أكثر ما
يقلقنا بشأن
[الموسيقى]
ارتفاع درجة حرارة المحيطات مما يعني أننا
نفقد الكثير من الشعاب المرجانية التي
تحيط بالجزر ،
لذلك لدينا هنا
الموجات فوق الصوتية التي لا تلامس عندما نكون في الماء
لدينا نظام مثل هذا
وسيكون مانتا راي
هنا حتى لا نقترب كثيرًا فنحن
لا نفعل  لا أريد إخافتهم
تمامًا كما لو كان الإنسان حاملًا ، نحصل
على نفس الصورة
التي نحصل عليها في المستشفيات وتسمح
لنا بمعرفة
ما إذا كان هناك جرو داخل مانتا
هنا في مشروع مانتا راي المالديفي
الذي جمعناه  بيانات نانوغرام للسنوات
الخمس عشرة الماضية
، سمحت هذه البيانات للباحثين
بتحديد الأنماط الرئيسية
في حركات مانتا في جميع أنحاء
البلاد ،
لذا فقد سمحت لنا بالعثور على المجالات الرئيسية
التي يعتمد عليها المانتا في
حياتهم اليومية
من أجل محاولة الحصول عليها.  المناطق
المحمية ، كلما زاد وعي الناس بأشعة مانتا
وبيئتهم ، كلما أرادوا حمايتها أكثر من خلال جعل
الناس يقعون في حب
أسماك مانتا راي ، يمكننا بعد ذلك المساعدة في تشجيعهم
على إجراء تغييرات في حياتهم اليومية -  الحياة
اليومية والعمل من أجل حماية ليس فقط
بيئة المحيط ولكن
البيئات التي يتكون منها كوكبنا